thanks for joining us America boy is in
Midland Texas
I like how are you I'm good how are you
today better than I deserve what's up uh
my wife and I live with my in-laws and
we want to buy a house I'm not sure how
to go about doing it cuz we have for
credit and a little bit of debt what's
wrong with your credit well I've got
about a 5/16 and I've never really done
anything to build credit the only thing
I've got going for me is our car
payments yeah and you've not only not
built credit you've not paid things on
time what what is behind or not paid
well as we've been paying it on time but
when I started I had no credit and so
I've just been building it with the car
we paid 20.6% interest and I had a loan
but I paid it off excite akin alone to
down pay the cars - you owe on this
ridiculous car ten thousand good lord
at 20% interest yet there you are
getting screwed okay
also let me negotiate the price though
what's like well your wife wouldn't let
you that's what I did right that's not
how we do stuff at my house um the key
how old are you I'm 29 okay and what's
your income sir I make about forty-five
thousand years depending on overtime
okay does your wife work outside the
home no sir she's a stay-at-home mom how
many children do you have - okay all
right um and is this the only debt
you've got uh I think we've got about
12,000 total in debt there was a bed
that he got that where she pays monthly
on and she's got a loan from one of
those little loans later that I show
they're not to renew again okay all
right the two of you are going to have
to sit down together and your first goal
needs to be to get out of that
completely and when you have no accounts
open about six months to a year later
you'll have no credit score which is
what you're going to want to do because
you've got to make a ripoff finance
company crap and you guys have been
buying stuff you shouldn't be buying
you're getting killed man you have
everything you all are buying is a high
interest rate they're killing you
they're beating the snot out of you all
in the name of you buying stuff you
don't need to buy so you can get a house
later so what I would do if I woke up in
your shoes as I would sell this car and
get rid of debt and get me a beater and
then I would get these other two loans
paid off as soon as possible is the car
worth what you owe on it um just a
little more than what we're doing now
you can still get out of it I'd get out
of it while the getting's good and just
get you a beater have you got another
car I have a pickup but I use it for
work and that's the only vehicle that
she's got to get around because I may go
to work and be gone three days or
something yeah well we need to get her
she lives with her parents right yes sir
there were had cars crap and her mom
works all the time okay then we need to
get her about a thousand dollar car her
getting around as a stay-at-home mom is
getting in the way of you all buying a
house okay okay that's the way I'm
looking at it I'm not sure you're gonna
do any of this stuff but this is what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes I
would sell that car I get those other
two loans paid off and I would get me a
little place to rent and get out of mom
and dad's basement and get the dignity
of standing on your own two feet then
I'd start saving aggressively for an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then I'd start saving my
down payment and that's going to take
you a little while I have a 401k and
stock purchase through the company I
work in I was stopped adding to that
until you get this mess cleaned up okay
and you have any money in the stock
purchase yes sir between my 401k and
thought searches I have about 15,000
almost 15,000 dollars and how much is in
the stock purchase um a little over
$5,000
I put 10% of every check right here in
there good I'd pull that money out
tomorrow that's not got a penalty on it
your 401k as a penalty on it and stop
putting money in your 401k use that
money to pay off the two loans and to
get her a little car because you're
selling that car now you're a hundred
percent debt-free as soon as you pull
those things off you could be debt-free
in a week if you get with it that feels
pretty good now you get on a real budget
and you start working together on a
written budget and your first goal is to
get out of the house your second goal is
to save an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and your third
goal is to it is to save your down
payment on your house it's going to take
you about a year and a half to save up
and during that time your credit score
will disappear so there's only two
worlds you want to be in for getting a
home as far as a credit score goes a
very high credit score or zero credit
score and a zero credit score comes from
having absolutely no accounts of any
kind outstanding or open they're all
paid off and they're all closed you have
any bad debt outstanding um there's
medical bills but people that I talked
to said they don't really go off of fat
their years people that you talk to or
idiots
of course they go off of that if they
report that as bad debt on your credit
bureau that's what's keeping your credit
score down okay so you got to go get
those medical bills and get them paid
off too when you catch this 5,000 out
you don't want to have any body on the
planet that you owe any money to ever at
all and six months later you'll have
until a year you'll have no credit score
and then you can qualify for a house but
if you walk around this 560 paying 20%
on this car living with your
mother-in-law dude you're getting killed
every time I turn around in this
conversation you hearing me your hair I
think you can do this but it's you guys
it's time for y'all take this dog by the
ears and make it make it bark okay you
can do this hold on I'm going to send
you a copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover and it'll show you guys exactly
what to do step by step to cause this to
happen but I gave you some pretty clear
instructions there if you'll follow them
exactly this will work
you deviate from them then you probably
got bad advice today